all hail the king so everybody I just
got back from seeing black panther and I
get to do something really exciting I
get to introduce you all to live hello
everyone
liz is my co-host on one of my podcasts
punch like your girl which is over on
the firewater Network there's always the
link in the description on every episode
I put up she is also my partner and yeah
we just saw Black Panther and to talk
about it um we'll keep it spoiler free
initially just so you can get a sense of
the vibe from us but we're probably
gonna start getting into spoilers before
too long but I'll try and give you a
heads up before we get there but you're
shaking in your whole day a sense you
liked it I did I really really enjoyed
it I didn't even say I loved it
I would I would say that it was just oh
it was beautiful it was so much more
than I expected um in terms of like
woman power and Bera there are some
really kick-ass ladies in this moment
there's so many I mean I had heard that
like I had read a like a headline that
was like yeah the girls were all this or
whatever and I was like oh okay but I
was like oh great love the ladies in
this movie beautiful world oh my gosh
the costumes in the hair sounds good
genetically this is an astounding movie
it just the this movie looks like
nothing else I've ever seen looks which
was ultimately that was the main thing
that I wanted out of this I didn't have
a particular set of expectations for the
plot but I wanted which was a good plot
but I didn't really have any expectation
that my expectation was I wanted to see
a world in a setting that I hadn't seen
before
and I got
believe that I got that here even better
than I got it in dr. strange and I had
and I was happy with dr. strange what I
saw it this is this is a much more
complete and all it like the vast
majority of this movie is set in Wakanda
I don't consider that to be a spoiler
but like that you spend a lot of time in
this world and it's awesome it's really
amazing at it it's just so gorgeous the
lights the technology the clothing the
the jewelry everything is just gorgeous
if they do not get like best costume
design so angry it's Oscars next year
how if they don't win I will be angry if
they don't get nominated oh wow well
we'll see what happens unfortunately
Oscars has a she has a long term memory
problem so things that come out never in
the frontier don't always do ah that
said get out was like a February release
to and that kind of crapped on our
nominations so I don't know maybe the
dynamics changing well
well great little touch it doesn't get
in a year and see if you're you're
either seething or or satisfied with the
world the performances are all grimy we
knew we already knew chadwick boseman
was good in this part because we saw him
in civil war yes I suppose that's worth
mentioning for people who don't listen
to punch like your girl because I know
wait few of you do that then watch this
channel please but in any case obviously
you know I don't have to go through my
credentials I've been living and
experiencing you know various
superheroes to various degrees for since
adolescence your background on these is
a bit more limited mostly to the films
in this case and unless I'm wrong yeah
that's cause these are the films yeah my
victim is more book related for the most
part and only recently graphic novels
my books so the last seven years or so
and more concretely and frequently the
last no two years or so yeah bout that
yeah - two and a half years since I
started loaning her stuff basically not
true I had some of my own stuff through
the library collection and I introduced
you to plenty so did i yourself on the
back no no fair's fair
no I I deserve that put me on and I had
done like I would write like Watchmen
and V for Vendetta and some of the major
titles of my own before that so wasn't
no I would I am still and by no means an
expert or anything and still very novice
but well I mean I think that's a nice
perspective to have though because
you're coming into someone who isn't
steeped in the lore and I'm not even
have you seen all the Marvel movies or
just I have seen most of them I have not
seen the Hulk's either one I have not
seen ant-man I have not seen I think I
fell asleep during one of the source
probably the second one if I were not
the most recent one no really good and
the best by my my point where I was
going with that was that it it kind of
shows you don't have to have been
steeping in this stuff either the source
material or even all the movies to get
something out of this film yeah yeah
yeah I would say so yeah there's but
I've seen most of them okay so yeah I
thought yeah yep so but I mean you know
I already mentioned chadwick boseman but
across the there was not a bad
performance in this movie and actually
what I threw what I stopped and thought
about it there really is the the caliber
in like the number of Oscar nominees and
Oscar winners who are in this movie when
I actually stopped and thought about it
maybe oh holy crap oh when we were
talking about it you forgot to mention
Angela Bassett cuz I'm pretty sure she
hasn't
know I'm thinking maybe for like what's
love got to do with
maybe possibly I don't know we'll check
we will get back to you but I mean it's
it's it's multiple including you car
along with Daniel Kuya who who I
actually didn't even realize was in this
but has a fairly significant part in it
which we can't really get into too much
without sort of dubbing into spoiler
stuff but I I think we kind of do need
to just go there because can we can we
can say like our favorite character oh
go for it go for so mine was Cherie who
I just called little fists throughout
the movie and who was just awesome and
sarcastic and had it was the tech geek
essentially and just ran everything from
distance and was amazing and adorable
and like you're you're introduced to her
by like flipping her button brother off
and her very first and that sets it up
pretty easily yeah I mean I guess that's
a minor spoiler but that's an early
woman I have a hard time choosing
picking a favorite character because
they're all right I mean I think the one
that's probably gonna stick with me I
gotta look this up because otherwise I'm
gonna get pronunciations wrong it was
probably a co a who was the general she
was nothing that's Danai gurira
i what very possibly butchering these
names apologies but she I mean hey
everybody was good in this movie but she
was striking and she had a strength and
a presence just just looking at somebody
I was I could just think about it like
how is that person not crumbling to
their knees right now just from the
strength of that look I mean she managed
to glare at a wig on her own head like
she did I don't know how she got her
eyes to do that but she did it was very
impressive
it was and I think we do need to get
displaced cuz otherwise we're just
talking very vague it's a good it's good
so this is your spoiler warning you it's
good go see it please
it's beautiful it finally acted it's a
great addition to the Marvel movies so
much womanpower so yeah so getting into
things spoilery getting getting a bit
more spoiler yeah I was I was kind of
pleasantly surprised just how prominent
the the female characters work and I
think a lot of that because I because
Marvel does not have a great track I
wasn't even gonna go there but you're
not wrong until then till relatively
recently at any rate cuz I mean Valkyrie
it was great
oh there's that yeah but that's like one
they don't ya know I know
black widows great Valkyrie is great
Scarlet Witch is pretty good but we had
to wait forever to get to in like you
know Civil War so or not so yeah we're
Civil War okay yes I sometimes mess up
the titles but like it took forever um
and we have like four or at least four
at least four prominent female carry
important but I think what's interesting
about it is it because of the way it
builds this world it never feels like
tokenism because it creates a world
where the role of women in this society
and what Condon society is not
restricted in a way that colonial
Western civilization is so you can look
because of how complete this world is
and it feels you look at someone like
the general who was my favorite and you
see her with her little crack squad of
these women with Spears and you just get
oh this is their league art that's the
elite guard in this society so it's not
like oh there's the woman they put in
that the movie put in a position that
would normally
yeah before the sake of empowerment like
no this is just how this society is
built so the it does in no way does it
feel like just throwing a bone to have
more female characters it feels properly
integrated into this amazing world that
they set up so I mean that was really
cool
I actually I I kind of want to talk to
the villains because we skipped over we
kind of had to yes
but yeah I definitely have some things
to say on that as well there's there's
because there's a couple of villains in
here now there's claw who we've seen
before because he appeared in age of
Ultron I really kind of dimly remember
him but well it's it's Andy Serkis
clearly having a blast
he's very clearly having a lot of fun
and I was shocked they killed him
because in the comics claw is basically
Black Panthers arch-nemesis white cloth
so that makes sense yeah Aaron with the
Panther yes but he he is he is Black
Panthers long-term recurring major
baddie like if you are gonna do who is
the villain for Black Panther it's Klaus
so the fact that they killed him
I was surprised by I'm kind of glad they
did so we could focus on the other
villain guy I think that was that was
the other thing that it surprised me
that it happened and then it surprised
me that I was okay with it yeah I mean
for the setup it was and it took me a
while to like him Michael B Jordan
character like he you you had to you had
to get a better sense of why he was
doing it and yeah he was in danger for
about the first half of being just
another mastering just another Malekith
just another Ronan the accuser just
another guy who comes in with an agenda
that we are told but don't really get
our fingers into but we get the depth in
him basically not that long after he
takes out Klaw and takes over the
primary villain role
because actually the movie I've been
focusing so much on claw up prior to
that that you you would not be making a
huge leap to think that Michael B Jordan
was just gonna be a minion to him so he
is all about the power and has really
great reason for it's such compelling
reason it was I mean it really well-done
it helps them Michael B Jordan is a such
a magnetic performer in the first place
that helped but it it also helped that
not only did we get the personal
motivation for this guy in terms of
feeling abandoned and the death of his
father and things like that just the
sheer anger that had been building fruit
yes yes I mean the boy I kind of want to
come back to that but so there's all
that but also part of what he's saying
also makes sense in that you know what
Conda has just shut itself off from the
world and there are people you know
black people people that are like them
suffering across the world and they have
the power and the means and the
technology to help and they don't and
now obviously he's still the bad guy
because he wants to use what kind of
technology to kill and overthrow and
enslave the people that he sees as a
pressing history whereas ultimately by
the end - i yeah and ultimately by the
end T'Challa has made the decision - yes
we are going to now take our technology
yeah we're gonna be more active in the
world we're gonna use it to help not to
hurt but you know they do give him but
all the all of the villains
except for Klaw who's just in it for
money and who's a dick but printed but
pretty much all the villains you know
being kill monger who's Michael B Jordan
and kill longer yes thank you what cobby
who is Daniel cool Ouya who K he's not
even really properly I did not see him
as
does side with kill monger though yeah
but I didn't go with me from it Oh in
both cases they are motivated primarily
by unchecked anger and it shows that
anger even you know earned and you can't
say you don't have a right to that anger
can lead to just did so much destruction
and I think that was that was a good
approach to take with him as a villain
yeah there was a lot of anger a lot of
pent up stuff even with the other tribe
the gorillas yeah yeah cuz they got
they've got a villain either but he kind
of almost is one in the beginning when
they had their little duel which awesome
I think I totally promote more like
fighting with the spear and a shield on
top of the waterfall like more battles
like that please all the time I will
maybe not all the time cuz I've made it
very unique but those were amazing
battle those were great battles and I
was impressed at how intense that first
one was because that should have felt
like a token action scene it should have
been like we know he's gonna win we know
the good guys gonna win this is like not
in the first twenty minutes but they may
they still made the hits hurt they still
made the threat real impressive I have
never seen a movie where people like
fall and thuds so hard and get thrown
around and it but the hits hurt a Davis
you're like oh like whenever someone
gets thrown or Falls or like it's
impressive it's it's painful the action
scenes were great and that was great too
was that there was just a like a variety
we had a card shape in South Korea we
had like this water we had two waterfall
battles we had you know the main
sequence we had like a spaceship fight
we had like so much going on yeah that's
you
Rhino charge we had rhinos there are not
also not enough rhinos in maybe like
charging yeah people know this is very
true I think if I ask for right now
obviously can you get me one of those
rhinos I'm looking into it so if there's
one criticism I'm gonna level yet and
this is truly the only thing I can think
of that while I was watching it was like
some of the early action scenes are a
little cut heavy and a little shaky cam
the one in the casino I think is
probably the biggest offender of that
and that's partially hindered also by
the fact that that one's probably got
the darkest lighting of any action
saying neither it wasn't often referred
it to the action the casino action scene
and the latest Star Wars movie I thought
you for that thing it's just so much for
bringing that back into my life okay it
wasn't even that bad like in terms of
shaky cam a few too many cuts offenses
it's minor and it's really only a couple
of fights early on because the major key
fights that need to visually flow well
did the fights between kill monger and
T'Challa the the big you know battle
between the tribes had the end that that
stuff is all well shot and clear and
well lit and works so when I make that
complaint
it's literally like probably a minute
worth of footage I'm complaining about
minorly
it's also I also enjoyed that was a
bunch of guns for fights
I love the spears there were almost no
guns in this I mean I claw had his hand
cannon thing yeah but that's not even
that's not really a proper gun no but
that was kind of it because it's it's
Spears and it's claws and it's against
like ecology and what 1 or 2 energy
weapons and yeah oh god yeah and you
know the technology was really cool and
really inventive as well both in terms
of what it did but also especially
visually because again they really Brian
Ryan Coogler who directed and co-wrote
this really embraced fully this the
whole afrofuturism aesthetic and this
whole idea of what if there was what if
Africa was never colonized what would
that technology look like if we just
remove all influence of how Westerners
built their technology up what would
that look like the suits were so cool
the black panther suits like that they
were like from the necklaces and like I
love the scene underground with like the
trains and how it's kind of like flowing
between their skin and like the zoo and
like little of both
and just whenever he got hit it absorbed
kinetic energy so it would glow this
like purple color I love anything that
glows like super water with the the
creature the river god yeah I was just
great that was really great all blue
glaze anything that glows in suits and
creatures I love that I think the one
other thing if you have you saw this
either not having seen the trailers not
having over examined the trailers or
having forgot them you would have
enjoyed it a bit more because I think
the trailers showed just a little more
than they should have specifically in
terms of making it clear that there were
going to be two people in black panther
suits duking it out because that's true
there was a there was a woman sitting
close to us like two down from us who
obviously who was super pumped for this
movie but obviously either didn't watch
all the trailers or had forgotten what
was in them because when Michael B
Jordan when that I heard her go and I
I'm sitting there going man I wish I
could have that reaction but I can't
because they showed that moment in the
trailer
good I had kind of forgotten
luckily let's see you're lucky then but
I mean there was something like I knew
Forrest Whitaker was gonna die oh yeah
that was enough that would that was a
nice you kinda like yeah oh if you were
the cause of this whole family like
rivalry and everything going on Oh at
the moment I knew that I would like love
you but goodbye you're gonna have to
sacrifice yourself speak a man because
he's connect to do this I just he'll say
how much I love the visual aesthetic of
the astral plane
yes oh gosh it was gorgeous yeah this
hey was I was like oh the Northern
Lights are here that did all of that was
none of them touring like the red sand
over them and getting married and just
like the weather they call them the
heart shapes the the heart-shaped herb
that heart-shaped herb yeah those were
cool yeah don't burn it all down you
need to use it later like well I mean
he's he wanted to go though yeah but
he's also he's not really he's not a
ruler he's a conqueror yeah he's not
there to to be the new protector of this
land he's he's there to he's Alexander
the Great's Julius is he well he's
Daenerys in the first in the first four
seasons of Game of Thrones not ruling
just conquering yep but yeah the the all
the stuff the conflict felt real and
genuine and even though we had a
character who you know kind of was a bit
of a turncoat and and sided with Kalmar
you understood why and it made sense
you know everybody seemed properly
motivated for everything that they were
doing when good guys bad guys and I love
that conflict between him
clay yeah fact that they were on
opposing sides and she's like yeah I'll
take you down in the weapon will you
kill me my love for Wakanda yes okay I'm
just gonna would not mess I don't think
anyone's know I would all when when she
and her guards were facing up against
kill monger I was really afraid they
were gonna kill her and I'm so glad they
didn't well I didn't think they were
gonna kill any of the major women
I was hoping not but and i i i did get
worried but I'm glad they didn't I'm
very glad as well and this if they kill
little sis but she escaped I would have
had to hold you back if they'd done that
and I and we've got we've got Martin
Freeman on Hannah's agent Ross who's a
whose name I did not know throughout the
whole movie who admittedly is just kind
of there he is mainly there just to
connect things back to the rest of the
MCU yeah so he's kind of standing in for
Nick Fury a little bit he's a token
white and I I kind of now that I've said
that out loud that he was kind of
subbing for Nick Fury I kind of wish
they just used Nick Fury yeah like I
almost feel like that would've what
we've been awesome that would have a
LoJack yeah yeah except I can't I having
trouble off the top of my head right now
remembering what his current status in
the movies is whether he's still
supposed to be pretending to be dead or
not I can't remember but I'm really yeah
it's a shield part of the MCU
remembering all that like if it was
logistical II possible I kinda would
have preferred Nick Fury to to agent
Ross it if I give I like probably
after we saw stop recording or somebody
in the comments will tell me if it is if
it's not if it does if it wouldn't make
logical sense someone's gonna point it
out thank you in advance for knowing for
yes explaining it yeah there's a lot to
keep track of in the Marvel Universe
right now even with just my meager
knowledge of the movies I'm just like
who is signing with who and what
happened this like secondary character
and like which villains have they killed
off and like what is Loki status right I
never know like it's low-key kind of
being nice it's who's he playing now
like I always forget that it's all
that's almost like what I think Loki
would prefer he wants you to not
remember whose side he's on I think I've
hit most of my major points liked it
like I had to really dig for the few
tiny I don't even really care nitpicks
that I had this was really good yes I
would say I didn't like claw as much as
you
i I found it very enjoyable I had fun
with him um and I I mean I knew foot I
wish I wouldn't have known Forest
Whitaker was gonna die and that was very
predictable but I mean that's kind of a
given like yeah um I mean and again I
really liked the fact that what they did
was kill monger like I really spent half
the movie being like he doesn't work for
me I'm really not liking him and then
like the emotional depth started to show
through and you got the backstory and
like I spent I'm like I want to punch
you but I also want to hug you and be
like oh honey hi I think the scene that
solidified him as a well-developed
villain was after he had beaten to chala
in the combat and then the instant they
started the ritual for him to have a
vision
I got super excited because I I wouldn't
have thought they would have done that
for it I don't mean like the what
Condon's would have done I didn't think
the movie would bother to show that it
was like the last part of their
tradition so we get to see what his
vision of community with his father is
I'm playing seeing soul man and that
really is what locks down you out oh I
get this guy and like his ending scene
was amazing there was a couple others I
can't remember right now but there was
another time where I was just like oh I
can't you know thank you
yeah it would it was kind of sad to see
him get I was like but I I think he
wanted they
yeah and that's also a character that I
mean if you don't kill them off you
can't really do much but repeat the same
arc you already did and you can't you
can't do a proper redemption on this guy
he's too uncontrollable it doesn't angry
yeah it doesn't work so just and I mean
there are some people who are just angry
and mid lives like that are left have
gone to the dark side for lack of a
better term and like are like a mixer I
took across the geeky streams and by
using that reference add another layer
under that there I go but yeah it that I
I don't think he could really given I
mean that is ending see made that very
clear
yeah he was not looking for redemption
so yeah it was it was kind of
heartbreaking it would and and you could
tell it it tore it all up inside yeah he
was not comfortable with when how all
this went down and how it ended he
that's a hard thing to learn about your
father like this is some some Greek
mythology styles like
go I think it was it was really well
summed up in two challahs own astral
plane thing where his father says to him
you're a good man and it's very hard to
be a good man and be king yeah it's very
there are some like Greek mythology
Shakespearean themes going on it was
just good I mean um let me put it this
way this was my most anticipated movie
for this year when this when 2018
started
traditionally my most anticipated films
are kind of starting in the hole because
then they have a history of letting me
down more often than not especially last
year last year a lot of films I was
really looking forward to let me down
this did not let me down at all this was
all I know I I apparently got so excited
my hair came down it was yeah well yeah
you know that's the pinyon of that's the
charging rhino in the room isn't it the
fact that ignore that a Nordic woman and
a British British descendent man are
sitting here talking about this movie I
think we need to close on that note
before we dig this hole any deeper so
thank you for coming to the movie with
me and agreeing to go on camera yeah so
if you enjoyed Liz and enjoy what
happens when the two of us talk together
I I this is an additional plug for the
punch like your girl podcast there'll be
a link down below there always is
there's also links for all the other
stuff you can do like support me on
patreon and follow me on Twitter and the
other podcast stuff all that stuff links
in the description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]